[Música]
no muy bien visto gracias
perdón bueno esto no sirve más
a pequeño facebook para empezar perdón y
quería ser el ballet en hover en el
colon pero no bueno igual está bueno no
un fail porque para los que estén
buscando en youtube videos the face a
las 4 de la mañana como hacemos todos
bueno como hacemos algunos entonces este
vídeo va a aparecer ahí al costadito no
hay más chance de que la gente vea esta
charla el algoritmo va a jugar a nuestro
favor ahí en youtube no escucharon
hablar del algoritmo no todos sabemos lo
que es el algoritmo sabemos que existe
pero que es un algoritmo específicamente
yo estuve investigando un poco y lo baje
un poco a palabras que todos podamos
entender no significa un algoritmo es un
conjunto prescrito de instrucciones o
reglas bien definidas ordenadas y
finitas que permiten llevar a cabo una
actividad mediante pasos sucesivos que
no generen dudas a quien debe hacer
dicha actividad no aplicado a las redes
entonces el algoritmo tiene la
instrucción de registrar no todo lo que
los contenidos que nosotros consumimos
para después ofrecer los contenidos
similares no sea el algoritmo sabe lo
que nos gusta y nos ofrece cosas que nos
gustan alto stoker no altísimo stoker el
algoritmo nos dice todo lo que sabe todo
lo que queremos y nos ofrece las cosas
que queremos
entonces aplicado a las redes funciona
así y lo vemos claramente en las
plataformas de música en las plataformas
de música sabemos que por qué por
ejemplo escuchaste arrien entonces
recomendamos para ti rey de og
y entonces por qué escuchaste radiohead
recomendamos para ti adele y por qué
escuchaste a de él recomendamos para ti
james blunt no y por qué escuchas james
blunt recomendamos para ti
antidepresivos
no se sale de james blunt sin medicación
sépanlo si estás en un momento james
blunt de la vida ya manos sabemos qué
hacer nosotros estuvimos ahí entonces si
lo llevábamos a la tierra entre nosotros
el algoritmo es algo así como un mosaico
completamente psycho entonces vos un día
vas a ese restaurante que atiende el
algoritmo mosso y le decís bueno me
gustaría comer unos riñoncitos bien
cortados finitos esté doraditos y el
regista registra le gusta la carne de
vaca les gustan las achuras doraditos y
va y te los trae al día siguiente u otro
día a base de si soy testigo matambrito
deseado puede ser doradito también y
registra de vuelta como otras cosas que
no son vacas también
y vas a un tercer día y te dices tengo
algo para recomendarle no ya el
algoritmo aprendió algo de nosotros
tengo un pollito deshuesado bien
doradito que le va a encantar yo así
bueno buenísimo si me encantan genial y
vas otro día y ya en el algoritmo estás
elevado y te dice no me pida nada yo ya
sé que es ofrecerle lo estuve pensando
acá tienes es próstata de mono
doraditas una
y lo decís no claro hay algo en la
recomendación que no estás terminando de
entender porque viste que me dio que a
veces falla el algoritmo a veces que un
toque le pifia y además lo que tiene de
sádico es que no para
tampoco el algoritmo no yo me compré un
aire acondicionado hace un mes hoy
todavía tengo ofertas de aire
acondicionado en el mail en mercadolibre
en facebook en instagram en newport en
todos lados ofertas de aire
acondicionado
[Aplausos]
entonces cómo hacemos para escapar del
algoritmo cómo hacemos que más gente se
entere que el algoritmo nos ofrece
solamente las cosas que nos gustan y que
hay un montón de contenidos para conocer
y de eso se trata te de que río de la
plata' no de conocer un montón de cosas
que no conocíamos y entonces acá somos
3.000 personas más los que están viendo
streaming más lo que vayan a buscar esta
charla bien es mucha gente pero nadie va
a ver esta charla del algoritmo si no
está buscando una charla sobre el
problema del algoritmo no entonces qué
vamos a hacer
vamos a hackear el algoritmo acá en el
teatro colony con esta charla bueno no
sería hackear lo sería porque no que
vamos a entrar por código no sería como
engañarlo un poco lo bueno engañarlo
tampoco sería la palabra sería como
inducir lo no es
bueno tampoco es eso la verdad la verdad
lo vamos a tratar de [ __ ] o sea estamos
en la catedral de la cultura argentina
de eso sabemos y lo vamos a tratar de
hacer con el algoritmo pero ojo porque
como buen psycho no es tonto el
algoritmo porque lo que viste de todo el
mundo le mete etiquetas a sus vídeos
pero el algoritmo si lo que está
etiquetado no es lo que hay en el vídeo
no te lo posiciona así que nosotros si
lo vamos a lograr acá viendo las cosas
que la gente quiere ver en youtube no
que quiere ver la gente en youtube
bueno si hay un poco de todo youtubers
también así que necesitamos tener
youtubers en este vídeo así le podemos
meter la etiqueta de youtubers y no
están acá arriba del escenario pero hoy
acá en el teatro colón está con nosotros
hola soy hermans y germán garmendia acá
está la foto de él es el rubio también
está rubios están todos moros y usted en
todos los los youtubers así que ya le
podemos meter a esta charla etiqueta
bueno facebook persa está youtubers
hola soy germán rubias morocha bien
gatos alguien dijo arena porque tengo se
van a morir con esta agarramos a medio
mundo en youtube
para qué
están listos para una au
ah
gatitos no te puedo creer un gatito no
son 22 gatitos me muero mira parece que
saluda
qué hace le está tomando la fiebre no te
puedo creer parecen personas ayer bueno
ya tenemos gatitos en el vídeo entonces
podemos etiquetar bien para se me fueron
los youtubers rubios morochos
gatitos gatos en inglés titans
en chino o gatos así se escribe gatos
que de la misma forma que se escribe
panchos eso es una curiosidad por eso es
que ellos les entran y hay los ghats
bueno que más tenemos que meterle esta
charla
para que se posicione para que el
algoritmo la posición necesitamos hacer
algo para los chicos unam boxing
los chicos se copan con los unboxing
vieron que se meten en youtube a ver
cómo otros chicos abren regalos jugar en
juguetes
parece loco pero si lo piensan nosotros
también lo hacíamos lo que pasa que no
se llamaban boxing se llamaba el
cumpleaños del compañero rico del curso
y entonces viste llegadas al cumpleaños
y acá y al tío con una caja si la sacaba
ayer un transformer que disparaba
bailaba lambada así a todos yo en un
ambos sing de mi cumpleaños me destaqué
el muñeco de frank chela en brigada cola
que no hace nada lo tenía que hacer vos
tenías
listos hasta 5 minutos que dura el
unboxing así que vamos a hacer un
pequeño unboxing acá para todos los
niños que les encanta abrir juguetes y
ver que viene vamos a hacer un boxing y
que tenemos aquí
es un balero que padre
es un balero vamos a enseñar como jugar
al balero entonces metemos tutorial
también y como es un juego gaming
así que clavamos 3 entonces para jugar
al balero niño se juega
de esta manera debemos asegurarnos del
cordel este bien dice citó y lo que
tenemos que lograr es que el balón
encaje en el mansiche
entonces ponemos el manchú que en esta
posición
[Música]
lo logramos
hemos superado el nivel 1 el nivel 2 es
igual que el nivel 1 no tiene ninguna
diferencia bien ya tenemos unboxing
metamos el hashtag de unboxing que
tenemos unboxing gaming tutorial y
gaming bien que más que más necesita un
buen vídeo para que se vea mucho en
youtube
con muchos viste los rusos que están
reservados buscaron crazy ryans porque
de repente hay un ruso y acompañante
lleva un oso y desigual afa que están
reloj con los rayas y bueno baryshnikov
estuvo acá en este teatro en el 98 y
dejó gente se quedaban no no querían
volver y venía acércate ruso bien él es
ruso
brass ryan no ruso
ryan bryant bien gracias crazy 'russian
red' crazy te rompo todo el colon no no
no no no no
tranquilo tranquilo otra cosa de crazy
ryan que no va más tranqui que otra cosa
vuelve estado
qué sé yo por ahí es mucho haber mirado
acá
tranquilo tranquilo con los gatitos que
están vivos doble guiño para youtube
mira crazy ryan con gatitos uma en su
posición a otro un perrito hay un crazy
ryan con perrito no te puedo creer que
divino bueno listo ya está ahí posición
bueno bueno bueno tranquilo bien bien el
crazy ryan bien bueno está a ryan
gracias bueno que más le hace falta un
vídeo para que se posicione en youtube
un challenge hoy vamos a hacer un chalés
ya les voy pidiendo que subamos la luz
de sala porque todos vamos a participar
de un chal en ninguno de los que
conocemos no del de tirarse agua en la
cabeza el desafío ese no pasa
[Aplausos]
bien doble fail
vamos a hacer un challenge' entre
nosotros vamos a poner el baník
challenges toque significa yo voy a
grabar con el vídeo voy a hacer dos
vueltas sobre mi eje eso lo estudie eje
en la primera vuelta se va a ver que el
colon está lleno de gente que vino a
verte dx río de la plata vamos a
celebrar vamos a festejar en la segunda
vuelta de esteban y sal en el chalet es
que todo se escondan entonces para la
segunda vuelta tienen que estar todos
metidos abajo si se tienen que tirar del
gallinero tírense las recomendaciones
que se metan por debajo de los asientos
la gente alta haga un esfuerzo sí y
bueno los que tengan problemas de
ciático metales fuertes
[Música]
yo voy a dar dos vueltas en la primera
digo qué bueno que esté x río de la
plata colom lleno colmado y en la
segunda tienen que desaparecer todos
podemos empezar un challenge como el
primer gil que se tiene un coso de agua
encima o sea sabes lo que facturó ese
para nada bien bueno entonces voy a
empezar con el vídeo tenemos blues de
sala le podemos dar más luz a la sala si
los veo bien a todos aprendamos todas
las velas no son velas bueno a ver voy a
empezar a grabar voy a dar vuelta a la
cámara bien ahí se ve bastante bien
bueno voy con la primera festejo en la
segunda desaparecen vamos
acá estamos los entes de tierra de la
plata
teatro colon lleno parece un sueño un
sueño cumplido no puedo creer tanta
gente tanta gente mirando
dónde están se fue fue un sueño nada más
funcionaba o funcionó bastante bien
paren
funciona muy bien
tengo para verlo solo en el celular pero
el arquitecto del color es tan genio que
pensó esto y si se fijan desde el
gallinero van a poder verlo también es
así que miran ahí quedó
miren hay tan
[Aplausos]
la gente mirando no hay nadie
bueno hay un hay un parque jugando a la
escondida perdían siempre no muy pero
bien funcionó yo creo que lo podemos
esto esto se puede visualizar
tranquilamente y bueno ya tenemos chalés
también para donde dejé el coso vamos a
etiquetar le salen ya este vídeo crazy
ryan challenge is y que un vídeo que se
ve mucho también en youtube que es lo
primero que tienen oa un fake no una
imitación y eso es muy loco porque no lo
van a poder creer pero incluso antes de
que esta charla termine ya ya está la
invitación está la copia viste cuando
algo sale medio loco y la gente lo
empieza a copiar fíjense nos metemos en
este momento en youtube esto es ahora
buscas
este de equis río de la plata
tremendo fail antes de que río de la
plata' del título que le pusimos recién
y mira está copiado iguales con la
apertura de todo eso
lo hacen y lo hacen igual y mira entra
con el cover
no está copiando todo es exactamente
igual mira ahí se cae
no te puedo creer copian todo fail el
balero
estás jugando al balero dejate de
hinchar
que más el crazy ryan con el hacha
como sabían es increible bueno ahora con
todo esto ya somos un poco más
conscientes del problema del algoritmo
cuál es el problema que nos muestra las
cosas que nos gustan de más que tratar
de buscar cosas distintas cosas que el
algoritmo no sabe que nos tiene que
recomendar para conocer un poco más y si
quieren subir un vídeo ya se ven algunos
truquitos para cargarlo
y a tame para yo no uso anteojos en
realidad pero viste que las charlas ted
la exposición al mejor si el orador
tiene anteojos
por eso lo sucede así que gracias y muy
amables
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bueno